[Musique]
détective, il y a une situation qui
exige le meilleur des meilleurs
manoirs en briques c'est tellement dangereux que nous avons
construit un mur autour de lui personne n'entre dans
un autre les dirigeants ont pris le maire et la moitié de
la ville en otage Je vais commencer les enchères
à 30 millions pensez-vous  peut le gérer
gérer il a besoin de gérer vous n'avez aucune information à l'
intérieur nous avons quelqu'un qui connaît les
manoirs en briques le condamné est mon partenaire je
dois prévoir de nous tester la première chance
vous obtenez ce que vous allez faire mettre
tout le dos de mon  tête mise en place mignon
ça va être très amusant
qui t'a appris à parler anglais
tellement bon shérif en ville il doit
te rendre un peu anxieux
a un plan
chic comme un style devinez quoi
[Musique]